ALX 2020 is a program focused on data
science and application to project
source from current topics and
biomedical research in this program we
will focus on methods for analysis of
big data and data wrangling essential
skills for biomedicine essential skills
for bioinformaticians as well as those
interested in other types of non biology
related research we will work with the
program participants providing support
and guidance into these topics our
expert team has been working for the
past several weeks to make sure that we
have interesting examples up-to-date
methods and a lot of resources that you
will be able to access for the next
month in this presentation I will review
the program topics show how our comics
logic programs work and give you a short
demonstration of practical assignments
we will work on together but let's start
from the basics what is their science
and how is it related to bioinformatics
the truth is both domains are very
similar but while data science assumes
no particular specialization and is open
to any type of domain knowledge by
informatics is specific to biological
domain knowledge with applications and
basic biological research as well as
clinical biotech pharmaceutical and even
agricultural projects thus the program
is structured to provide you with
insights into various data types formats
and challenges and then it will
introduce you to the typical processing
analysis and interpretation methods for
these data in week one
we will focus on onyx data types
challenges associated with big data in
an overview of methods to handle and
prepare data for in-depth analysis in
week 2 of the program will focus on
multivariate analysis methods and
examples that showcase how machine
learning and artificial intelligence
work in real life many of the exercises
we prepared will include source code and
practical assignments that you can
complete in R and Python these two
languages are used in both by
informatics domains and many others many
statistical tools visualization packages
and workflows in these languages
them a good choice if you plan to dabble
and data processing and analysis in any
domain as the world is getting tired of
the overhyped terms like machine
learning big data in AI we will actually
take the time to see all of them in
application to real challenges that
affect all of us because the rise of
computational technologies related to
data collection processing and analysis
coincides with the development of
high-throughput automated technologies
that are now used to produce thousands
of genomic sequences across hundreds of
animal species every day so let's talk
about the program in our first session
we'll review various types of data that
are used in biomedical research some of
them will be properties you might be
familiar with types of patients disease
stages or associated characteristics but
others you might learn about for the
first time such as genomics or
metagenomics these are collectively
known as comics data but the different
file formats different properties and
the biological dynamics they represent
very significantly so we will explore
examples from Cancer Research viral
infection and microbiome composition
areas that have a major impact on all
aspects of our lives these projects will
give you an insight into datasets that
you can start exploring to develop a
research question about how these
conditions are diagnosed what causes
them to appear and develop and how to
treat conditions like acne food
intolerance or cancer these datasets
vary by type and dimensionality which
are just some of the data properties we
will discuss importantly as we move
forward you will see how analysis
methods or even visualization Styles are
linked to the data properties in your
project in our second lecture we will
focus on some of the major challenges
presented by large data requiring
special attention to exploratory data
analysis and domain expertise to help
separate technical noise from biological
signal in our data we will also explore
how major research principles of
reproducibility requires to the
a deep understanding of methods we use
and incorporate a clear record of
settings data transformation steps and
outputs along the way the purpose of
statistical analysis is to learn more
about some population of interest like
humans in the whole world but very
rarely if ever do we have access to
every individual in the population so
typically we can sample a subset of the
population with a sample in hand we seek
to either summarize that data using
descriptive statistics or use the data
to make some prediction or statement
about that population using inferential
statistics these traditional methods of
statistical analysis were developed to
work with demographics astronomy and
biological data all of these domains
have been transformed by the emergence
of big data where each sample can be
described by thousands or even millions
of data points that can be generated
with increased speed due to the
automation of data collection processes
in many ways statistical analysis helps
develop an intuitive representation or
description of data properties helping
us find relationships between various
types of data we have about our sample
each data type can be visualized
focusing our attention on a trend that
is important once data sets grow
multivariate analysis methods can help
discover trend and big data and describe
the complex relationships between data
points in each sample in this session we
will discuss the relationship between
big data that is generated by automated
technologies called high-throughput
technologies and the methods of analysis
that are used to explore describe and
study the data leading us to the machine
learning paradigm
domain knowledge is critical for data
cleaning and processing before we
analyze data to inform our conclusions
in the third session we will discuss how
each type of data is associated with the
specific steps designed to eliminate
technical noise and Link direct or raw
output from an instrument with a studied
element contained in knowledge databases
these include DNA variation gene
expression protein abundance and
composition properties of microbial
communities these all are very different
types of data that we will learn to
associate with or describe different
samples in a project to generate a data
set or a matrix of continuous and
categorical data that can be analyzed
processing steps specific to each type
of omics data will be reviewed then we
will see how each type of data can be
visualized and summarized to examine all
of the variables before making
inferences from data these methods will
help us catch mistakes explore patterns
in the data find violations of
statistical assumptions generate
hypotheses and because if you don't
you'll run into issues that will take a
whole lot longer to discover an address
including leading to incorrect
interpretation so that's why we will
spend a whole session talking more about
exploratory data analysis this type of
exploratory analysis includes many
methods and packages that will be
expanded on using practical examples in
our in Python we will learn how to plot
histograms scatter plots and bar plots
to find relationships between there and
use these for every will representations
to spot technical noise that is
important to illuminate before we
proceed with the next steps we will also
learn about what the biology of the data
means when we explore these patterns and
then we will have exercises designed to
explain the code for these types of
visualizations in both R and
I thought as a result we will see how
important it is to understand the
biology behind the datasets that we use
as in many cases we can filter out
technically improbable variation only to
discover that they actually represent
meaningful patterns in the study at hand
as a result of these preparatory
sessions we will be ready to explore
datasets prepared for the program and
analyze them in depth for variability
and patterns we will take a few examples
and learn about the logic behind each
type of data for example we will see how
many projects use various datasets and
combine them together to explain
conditions and which elements are used
to define variables in each project we
will also learn about ways we can
validate our findings by relying on
large repositories in validation studies
in some cases we will discover that many
attempts and multiple comparisons are
essential before we find a true pattern
that is relevant to a question that we
might be willing to explore these
sessions will conclude week one of the
program and you will be equipped to
explore various types of omics data
using data wrangling techniques that
extract useful signals from big datasets
in week 2 of the program will focus on
multivariate analysis methods and
examples using machine learning and
artificial intelligence in session 6 we
will start a discussion of analysis
methods that can be grouped into
supervised and unsupervised methods we
will discuss how statistical analysis is
different from machine learning and what
exactly makes learning deep we'll have a
chance to see the different methods that
are commonly used to group data objects
by feature similarity and how innovative
mathematical thinking led to an
emergence of predictive algorithms that
can be trained to do prediction our next
session will be an overview of typical
methods and challenges in data mining
where unlabeled data is explored for
patterns
that might be significant for data
structure and organization for example
we will compare how different clustering
and dimensionality reduction techniques
can provide us with different types of
insights about the data and how we can
use the linkage criterion and distance
metrics define tune the algorithms we
apply to different types of data in
session 8 we will turn to supervised
methods of analysis and speak about key
concepts and examples where such data
analysis is used we will discuss how
training test and validation datasets
are prepared and different types of
classic methods for classification that
are used and the useful data
transformations that they can be
equipped with to deal with complex
features in noisy data and we will also
discuss feature selection that can help
us explore feature significance for
model stability and accuracy in session
9 we will discuss how models are
evaluated and tested to avoid
overfitting and misrepresentation using
tested validation methods for both
computer science and biological
standpoint we will see how accuracy of
the model is determined by key features
that algorithm picks to improve accuracy
and study feature significance and then
we will compare classification and
dimensionality reduction approaches to
understand how they can be used in a
complimentary mode we will also speak
about making these models more
transparent and explainable when we
present the results to our collaborators
finally we will speak about machine
learning and production and use a number
of examples that can help us see the
future of machine learning and AI
especially in biomedical applications we
will discuss classification and
application to biomarker discovery for
diagnostic purposes and an application
to target discovery and selection of
treatment and we will also speak about
the role big data plays in biomedical
research that regularly generates data
to develop a hypothesis that is then
analyzed and used for accuracy
improvement
and how this process is affecting
clinical care today and we will also
discuss other applications that are
already yielding significant results for
pharmaceutical and biotechnology
companies around the world to join the
program and get access to all of these
resources you will first have to
register on the science coach website
that is enriched with additional
coursework and many examples that you
will have access to during this program
the courses will be available for you to
complete and add to your personalized
profile where you can track your
progress and communicate with mentor or
program trainers your activity will be
assembled under your profile to show you
the overall progress with important
information then can help us discover
technical issues or lack of
understanding of a specific topic that
might be important for your project we
will also provide you with cloud access
to the team Island for computational
platform for processing of large-scale
next-generation sequencing data there
you will be able to run complex
bioinformatics pipelines without slowing
down your own computer and develop a
logical understanding of many of the
methods that we discuss throughout the
program after you have prepared the data
we will also explore the code behind
each step so that you can understand how
it works and modify it to fit your
project needs the practical coding
assignments will also help you
understand the R and Python code
elements that will be a part of any data
science project you end up working on in
your future these assignments are also
tracked and included under your profile
I am excited to be a part of this
program together with you I want to
highlight that the program materials and
many of the practical tools that we will
use were designed and tested by a whole
team of researchers and our team at Pine
I want to specifically mention the names
of dr. Alfred Tauber and dr. Lena
Brodsky that have put a significant
effort and resources to develop these
materials for your use welcome to data
science onyx 2020